ALAN ARCHULETA AT KINS BASED-
PORCHES BRADFORD COME BY ADAM
CORTEZ HE ALLEYNE DIED THEY'RE
ALSO ADMIN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERZBERG WAY SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED LEYVA
THE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN- A CELLO BOW
HAND PORTION TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER TURN ON BERG BY CAL SKI
WINNER WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER TODAY BY
SENATOR MEN. AND THEN PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA WHEN YOU'RE
READY SENATOR MAN. GOD OF OUR
ORDINARY DAYS AND NIGHTS GOD OF
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES. THIS DAY
WE PRAY. GUIDE OUR DISCERNING
AND ARE DECIDING. A TUNE OUR
HEARTS TO THE MURMURINGS BOTH
OF PEACE AND A DISQUIET. SO
THAT AWARE OF RISKS AND A
PROMISE. WE MOVED TRUST FULLY
INTO THE FUTURE. I CLOUD OUR
EYES TO KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO
LEAVE WHAT TO SEEK. AND WHAT A
HOLD FOR THE JOURNEY. THAT WE
WILL FIND OUR FEET ON THE RIGHT
TRACK. WALKING THE MERCIFUL
PATH LED BY YOUR ON AIRING
SPIRIT. WE ASK ALL THAT WE ASK
YOUR NAME. COMMENT. CENTER'S
LATEST GERMAN PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART AS WE HONOR OUR
FLAG AND PAY RESPECT AMENDMENT
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND. ISRAEL THE BEST SONG. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MEMBERS
REMOVING THE MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF JULY
FIVE THROUGH EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
SENATOR CORTESE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. A MAN
PRESIDENT REQUESTS UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW SENATE BILL
FIVE SIXTY FOUR FROM A GROSS IN
ROLLING TO RETURN MEASURE TO
THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE DESK WILL
NOTE. PART MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
ON TO CONSIDER- I'M SORRY
SENATOR DODD I APOLOGIZE PLEASE
PROCEED. ON MY- HOLD ON. OKAY
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE EIGHTY B. EIGHT
FORTY FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FROM THE CONSENT PLACE
ON THIRD READING THANK YOU SIR
THE DESK WILL NOTE MEMBERS
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DO UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SEEING AND HEARING
THEN WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING FILE. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO TWENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS SEVEN NINETY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SOME LEGAL THEM
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING
FILE WILL BE DEEMED DREAD.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
BATES WE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF EDWIN LAU READ
TO THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY. AND
HEALTH APPEALS BOARD HEW CROOKS
TO THE VETERANS BOARD. NYBERG
JENNIFER SCHMIDT AND KAREN
TIENEN TO THE BOARD OF PILOT
COMMISSIONERS THESE APPOINTEES
WERE ALL APPROVED ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU AND
PRESENT JUST TO SPEAK VERY
BRIEFLY I I'VE I'VE KNOWN TO
CROOKS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS-
HERE'S A FINE VETERINARY GOOD
PUBLIC SERVANT HE WILL MAKE AN
EXCELLENT APPOINTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. I. ATKINS. I
HATE FIVE BACKER. HI FORGES I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
CORTESE I DALLY I DONT. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE
DOLLARS I GROW. HI HERZ BERG HI
WHERE SO. HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
I FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN. I AM BERG I
BY CASTING I WINNER. WELL I.
WAY SO I'D- PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. WINNER THANK YOU
HIGHS THIRTY NINE TO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO IS TE
CONFIRMATION OF THE GAL THE
LARVA DON G. RUN TIME NO. AND
MICHAEL MARK TO THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD THESE
APPOINTEES WERE ALL APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
THIRTY. I RESPECTFUL ASKS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BAIT. I BACKER. HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY IT- I
CORTESE I DALLY. I DON I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I BLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE. I HURTS
BERG HI WITH SO HI HER TADO I
JONES FIVE KM LONGER I LAYERED.
I LABOUR I THE MON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN FIVE NEWMAN
I NIELSEN I- TELEVOTE HI PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG. HI WHAT KASKY FIVE WINNER.
WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ON THE MOUND HI WINNER.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FOR
MOVING THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATOR BATES THANK YOU
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JOYCE
DUDLEY AND SHARE OF INGRID
BROWN BROWN TO THE COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING MISS DUDLEY IS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND SERVES AS
COMMISSION CHAIR SHARE OF
RONNIE IS THE SHERIFF CORONER A
MONO COUNTY THESE APPOINTEES
WERE BOTH APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR PORCHES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SHARE OF BRAWN FOR
DISAPPOINTMENT- MANY VIEWERS
FELT THE EARTHQUAKE THAT
HAPPENED. A FEW DAYS AGO. AND
IF YOU DIDN'T I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU WORK- BUT I WAS IN
KHAN I WAS IN CONTACT WITH THE
SHERIFF AND- I THINK HAVING
THAT TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP WITH
THAT DEGREE OF PROFESSIONALISM.
IT'S MY HONOR TO REPRESENT MONO
COUNTY AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU NOT TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF-
THIS NOMINATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR BORDERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE HI
BECKER I FORGES. I BRADFORD I
COME BY IT- I PROTECT THESE. I
DALLY I DONT HI TORONTO I
EGGMAN. HI GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
FIVE GROWTH. I HEARD SPURRED BY
WAY SO BY HER TADO FIVE JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I
LIVE MY OWN. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S HI MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTINO. I. ROSS I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG. I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER. WELL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
RUBIO I WEINER FIVE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED BY ITEM THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF RACHEL
WAGONER AND DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING AND RECOVERY PRIOR TO
THIS ROLE DIRECTOR WAGONER
SERVED AS A DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
SECRETARY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND BEFORE THAT WAS
CHIEF CONSULTANT TO THE CENTER
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH FUNNY UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
CONFIRMATION YOU KNOW IN MISS
WAGNER WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HE WAS ALWAYS OPEN TO-
BOTH PARTIES AND SHE WAS ALWAYS
VERY RESPONSIVE SHE'S ALSO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S VERY RESPONSIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY SHE UNDERSTANDS BOTH
SIDES ARE ACTUALLY ALL SIDES
AND SHE'S WILLING TO TAKE ON
THE TOUGH ISSUES AND DO THE
RIGHT THING SO I WOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT A MISS WAGNER AS I DID
IN RULES AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR BREAUX
SENATOR DODD. THERE'S BEEN A
PRESENT MEMBERS I SPOKE I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS
NOMINEE- I'VE HAD THE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH HER IN CENTER WATER ON
THAT IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
FIRES- WHICH HE WAS WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
SHE WAS INCREDIBLY- RESPONSIVE
ATTENTIVE. AND IN AND HELPFUL
ALSO THIS LAST YEAR TOO I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH- ALSO IN HER.
SINCE SHE'S BEEN ON THE JOB WE
ARE WORKING WITH HER ON A
RESPONSIBLE JUST BOTTLE BILL
WHICH IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
BUT- I FOUND THE SAME
CHARACTERISTICS WITH- I
STRONGLY. RECOMMEND THAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODSON
RECOUNTS SKI YEAH MAN PERSON I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
MISS WHACKED HER WHEN SHE WAS
THE CHIEF CONSULTANT THAT'S
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE. FOR TEN YEARS HERE
IN THE SENATE AND I KNOW HE
HEARS THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT
TO HAVING. A REWORKING OUR
BOTTLE BILL IN COMING UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE THE ENVY
OF THE WHOLE WORLD AND THAT SHE
DOES IS IT MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SAID SHE DOES HAVE A- UNIQUE.
SKILL OF BRINGING PARTIES
TOGETHER AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER. ENTERED AS A
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU CENTER
RIGHT KELSEY CENTER NIELSEN-
PRESENT LEADING CHILDREN'S
CENTER I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF RICHARD WAGNER. DEALING WITH
HER IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WHICH IN THIS RESPECT A LITTLE
DIFFERENT USUALLY YOU HAVE TO
CALL THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
RACHEL WOULD CALL US THE
MEMBERS AND OF COURSE I'D
EXTENSIVELY DEALT WITH HER WITH
THE FIRE ISSUES WELL. HE WAS
ALWAYS RESPONSIVE AND COURTEOUS
AND AS I SAY NOT JUST RESPOND
TO THAT BUT SHE GOT TO YOUR
FIRST AND SHE'S WELL WORTHY OF
THE CONTINUING SERVICE IN THE
STATE. I KNOW SHE'LL DO A GOOD
JOB IN THIS POSITION ARE
TONIGHT. THANK YOU CENTER
NELSON MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE I BACKER. FIVE FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE I GOTTA I
CORTEZ THE- HI DALLY. HI DODD.
ARE YOU THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN.
ADMIN I LASER FIVE DOLLARS I
GROW FIVE HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO FIVE JONES I CAN'T
LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE IN I
LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A CHILL OF BOTH. I
PAN I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I
REVIEW. FIVE SKINNER I STERN I
AM BERG. HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WINNER. WELL HI I WAS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ONTO UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE
GONNA START WITH FILE ITEM
FORTY SENATOR CABALLERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
KABBADI AUTO AN ACT RELATING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CENTER
CABRERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT RIGHT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AS B. TWENTY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK TO CONCUR IN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
TECHNICALIN NATURE THE BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND HAD THIRTY
EIGHT I VOTED NO NO VOTES IN
THE SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CENTER COVER YOUR OWN MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE'RE NOW MOVING
TO FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT.
THIS IS BOB THE IN MY TIME IN
THE ASSEMBLY I AUTHORED AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX WHICH
CREATED THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SELF GENERATION BILL CREDIT
TRANSFER PROGRAM AND WHAT THAT
DOES IS ALLOWS A LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO GENERATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN ONE PLACE
AND USE IT IN ANOTHER WITHIN.
THEIR CITY. OR COUNTY- THERE OF
SENSE BEEN AMENDMENTS TO AT UC
AND CSU BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER OVER
NORTH G. TWO EXPAND THE PROGRAM
TO J. P. A.'S AND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GORDON TO EXPAND THE
AMOUNT OF POWER INVOLVED. THIS
BILL EXPANDS THE PROGRAMS TO
INCLUDE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
ALL THE SAME PROVISIONS THAT
EXIST FOR PRE EXISTING
GOVERNMENT EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES
IT'S RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES IN THE
PROCESS THERE'S NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN I WAS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO DECEMBER
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE SENATOR ARCH ALETTA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATO ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO VETERANS. CENTER
CHULA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY FOUR. WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE DILIGENT
EXPLAINED EGGS GREAT WORK
OUTSTANDING WORK OF OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AS A MANAGED
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
IT IS AMAZING THE WORK THEY'VE
DONE TO SERVE AND REPRESENT OUR
VETERANS AT THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC CAL VET PUT INTO PLACE
A SET OF VITAL PROGRAM TO
SAFEGUARD VETERANS UNDER THEIR
CARE AT THE EIGHT VETERANS
HOMES THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TOP
PROFESSIONAL REPRESENTATION NO
DOUBT. STAFF AND RESIDENTS
ALIKE WERE TESTED FREQUENTLY IN
ANY INFECTIONS WERE CONTAINED
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. THE
DEDICATED STAFF OF ALL THE
BETTER HOMES SERVED OUR
VETERANS. WITH PRIDE AND HONOR
IT'S A SET UP VITAL VISITS WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS AND ESTABLISHED
IN RICHMOND PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT HYSICAL MENTAL AND
SPIRITUAL WELL BEING OF THE
RESIDENTS THE VETERANS WHO WHAT
TAKEN CARE OF. THANKS TO THEIR
EFFORTS THE VETERANS HOMES IN
OUR STATE. THEY SUFFERED A TINY
FRACTION OF THE TRAGIC LOSS
THAT OCCURRED IN OTHER LONG
TERM FACILITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. SAFEGUARDING THOSE
THAT SERVED OUR COUNTRY WITH
DISTINCTION IS AN HONOR. AND
THESE HIGHLY PROFESSIONAL STAFF
MEMBERS DID EXACTLY THAT AND
THEY DID IT WITH PRIDE EACH AND
EVERY DAY. THEY'RE CONSISTENT
CARE FOR OTHERS IS THE MOST
DESERVING OF THIS RECOGNITION
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK YOU
JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
THIRTY FOUR. AND THANKING. IN
REALIZING THAT THE HARD WORK OF
SO MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO SERVE
OUR VETERANS IN OUR CALVIN
HOMES WILL NOT BE GOING WOULD
NOT GO UNRECOGNIZED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN EYES THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR ALSO SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA RELATIVE TO
LATINO VETERANS DAY. IN ORDER
TO LET THEM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE MEMBERS TO
ALLOW US ALL. TO UNDERSTAND
THAT. WE ARE. CLOSING OUT THE
SUMMER SEPTEMBER WOULD BE RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER IN SEPTEMBER
IS A VERY IMPORTANT DAY FOR ALL
OF US. A LATINO VETERANS I
SPEAK UP. I RISE MADAM
PRESIDENT TO PRESENT SENATE
SEVEN WHICH PROCLAIMS SEPTEMBER
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
LATINO VETERANS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. S. C. R. THIRTY
SEVEN PAYS TRIBUTE AND HONOR
THE LATINO MEN AND WOMEN
SERVING ACROSS ALL BRANCHES OF
OUR ARMED FORCES PAST AND
PRESENT WHO HAVE DEVOTED SO
MUCH TO OUR COUNTRY LATINO
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY OF AMERICA
THERE ARE COUNTLESS STORIES OF
LATINOS OFFERING THEIR SERVICE
AND OFTEN GIVING THEIR LIVES.
IN THAT SERVICE. WHETHER IT BE
A PART OF PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT
ROUGHRIDERS THE NATIONAL GUARD
REGIMENT. FOR THE SIXTY FIFTH
INFANTRY REGIMENT LATINOS HAVE
BEEN AND REMAIN VITAL TO PART
OF OUR ARMED FORCES. TODAY
LATINOS MAKE UP 15% OF
AMERICA'S FIGHTING MEN AND
WOMEN. PLANE GROUPM THE
PROVIDING CRITICAL ROLES IN
EVERY MAJOR AMERICAN CONFLICT
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR IN FACT
LATINO VETERANS HAVE BEEN
AWARDED THE CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL
OF HONOR OVER SIXTY TIMES MORE
THAN ANY OTHER ETHNIC GROUP IN
AMERICA. THIS DISTINGUISHED
MILITARY RECORDS OF LATINOS AS
A MARKER OF THEIR INCREDIBLE
DEDICATION THIS COUNTRY THEY
FOUGHT FOR A NATION THAT DID
NOT ALWAYS SEE THEM AS EQUAL
OFTEN SEGREGATING THEM OR
DENYING THEM JOBS THAT WE'RE
WORTHY OF THEIR SKILLS. ALL
BECAUSE OF THEIR ORIGIN OF
THEIR ANCESTORS YET THEY STILL
FOUGHT SERVED WITH HONOR THE
DEAD OF OUR GRATITUDE CAN NEVER
BE REPAID BUT IT CAN BE A
KNOWLEDGE. MAY WE HONOR THE
SERVICE AND DEDICATION OF THOSE
WHO HAVE GIVEN SO MUCH TO OUR
FREEDOM REMEMBER IN OUR LATINO
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE THIS
GREAT COUNTRY FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ONCE S. C. R. THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETAMEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT LATER DOWN THE
CENTER IF YOU'D LIKE TO PAY A
LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA HONOR TO
THESE VETERANS. RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET. IN THE CIRCLE OVER
THERE BETWEEN THE SP ONE AND SP
TWO TODAY YOU CAN MEET AT LAST
THERE IS A STATUTE RIGHT ACROSS
FROM THE PEACE OFFICER MEMORIAL
CULTURAL DONALD. PEOPLE DON'T
MUCH NOTICE THAT STATUTE BUT
IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO GO AND-
PAY RESPECT TO VICTIMS AND
THESE. LATINO SOLDIERS THEN I'D
ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A- OF
SOCIALIZATION I'VE WORKED WITH
FOR A LOT OF YEARS CALLED THE
G. I. FORM. AND THESE ARE
HISPANIC BAPTISTS AND THEY
STAND UP FOR EACH OTHER. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND LADIES IN GENERAL I MUST
RISE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THIS RESOLUTION. NOVEMBER
ELEVENTH IS VETERANS DAY FOR
ALL AMERICANS REGARDLESS OF
YOUR RACE YOUR GENDER. IT
DOESN'T MATTER NOVEMBER
ELEVENTH IS THE DAY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE ALL OF OUR VETERANS
AND THE SACRIFICES THEY HAVE
MADE. BUT TINA VETERANS
HISTORICALLY HAVE SERVED IN OUR
MILITARY IN A NON SEGREGATED
MILITARY- THAT IS NOT TRUE. FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN VETERANS- IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THE TUSKEGEE
AIRMEN WHO CAME IN UNDER
SEGREGATED MILITARY. THEY WENT
O THEIR BASIC TRAINING THEY
WENT ON TO THEIR- REGIMENS AND
IT WAS SEGREGATED. AND WE DON'T
HAVE A VETERANS DAY SET ASIDE.
FOR JUST BLACK AMERICANS WE
DON'T HAVE ONE SET ASIDE JUST
FOR ASIAN AMERICANS WE DON'T
HAVE ONE SET ASIDE FOR ANY
OTHER GROUP OF AMERICANS YET
TODAY WERE CONTEMPLATING
SETTING ASIDE A- ANOTHER
VETERANS DAY SPECIFICALLY FOR
LATINO VETERANS- AND I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S APPROPRIATE
THOUGH- I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND-
THE PRIDE WITH WHICH THE AUTHOR
SPEAKS- AND I UNDERSTAND THE-
INTENT BEHIND IT. WHAT YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER IS THAT OUR
MILITARY IS SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE-
THE BASIS IS UNITY WHEN YOU
JOIN THE MILITARY YOU DON'T
JOIN. A PARTICULAR MILITARY YOU
DON'T JOIN A LATINO MILITARY OR
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MILITARY
ASIAN MILITARY YOU'RE ALL ONE.
IT'S LIKE STAYING IN THE ARMY
YOU'RE ALL GREEN RIGHT. AND
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS THAT'S HOW
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE IF IN
THE MILITARY. WE STARTED. KIND
OF SELF DIVIDING ONE ANOTHER
THE WHOLE THING FALLS APART YOU
HAVE TO HAVE UNITY YOU HAVE TO
HAVE PEOPLE WHO COME INTO AN
ORGANISATION UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOUR
RACE IS OR WHERE YOU CAME FROM
THAT YOU'RE ALL WORKING TOWARD.
THE SAME MISSION. AND WHEN
PEOPLE START TO SEE THEMSELVES
IN VIEW THEIR SERVICE.
DIFFERENTLY THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN THEIR PEERS. IT
MAKES THE JOB MORE DIFFICULT
AND THE ONE THING THAT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY DEPENDS ON IS
THAT WE HAVE A MILITARY THAT IS
UNITED NOT ONLY YOU KNOW
PHYSICALLY GEOGRAPHICALLY BUT
PSYCHOLOGICALLY. IN THIS
RESOLUTION THOUGH IT DOESN'T.
PHYSICALLY SEGREGATE OUR TROOPS
IT IS A PSYCHOLOGICAL
SEGREGATION WHEN YOU START TO
TELL ONE GROUP THAT THEIR
SERVICE IS SO MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN THOSE OF THE
OTHERS THAT THEY GET A SEPARATE
DAY AND I THINK THAT IS NOT THE
MESSAGE THAT WE WANT TO SEND.
I'M CERTAIN THAT THAT'S NOT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT. BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY THAT IS THE
CONSEQUENCE OF PUTTING FORWARD
A RESOLUTION LIKE THIS SO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR I
MUST OPPOSE THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR MELINDA'S SENATOR
AIKMAN. I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I- I RISE IN UPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. AND YOU KNOW
AS A AS A LATINA AS A WOMAN AS
A VETERAN- I CAN BE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS AND STILL BE A
PROUD AMERICAN AS I AM AND A
PROUD VETERAN. BUT YOU KNOW IT
IS NOT HARD FOR ME TO STAND FOR
VETERANS ON VETERANS DAY AND I
DO THAT. AND IT'S NOT HARD FOR
ME TO STAND FOR LATINOS ON THE
TUESDAY AND I DIDN'T DO THAT
AND FOR WOMEN'S DAY. AND I
THINK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ISSUES
LIKE UNITY WE CAN LOOK AROUND
AND I CAN NO THE GENERAL ROSS
WOULD STAND FOR ME. AND I CAN
LOOK AROUND I CAN KNOW THAT
CAPTAIN NEWMAN WOULD STAND FOR
ME. I CAN LOOK AROUND I KNOW
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW I WOULD
STAND WITH THEM AND THEY KNOW
THAT. AND I THINK A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN WE- PEOPLE TRY TO
SAY WE'RE SEGREGATING OURSELVES
WE'RE RECOGNIZING. I THINK IN
RECOGNIZING THAT. PEOPLE HAVE A
LOT OF PRIDE. IN FAMILY MEMBERS
AND SERVICE. A LOT OF PRIDE IN
THEIR CULTURE AND WHEN THOSE
TWO THINGS ARE. ARE MELDED
TOGETHER. I KNOW FROM Y FAMILY
WHO CAME OVER AS IMMIGRANTS AND
PROUDLY SERVED. AND MY FAMILY
UP UP. WITH THE PICTURES OF OUR
LADY WAR LUPE AND THE POPE- AND
JFK WAS ALSO MY UNCLES. IN
PROUDLY IN THEIR UNIFORMS. AND
IT WAS A REAL THING OF HONOR IN
MY FAMILY AND WHEN I WENT TO
THE MILITARY. IT WAS A THING OF
HONOR FOR ME AS WELL. SO WHERE
WE STAND AS AMERICANS WE STAND
FOR ALL OF US. RIGHT WHEN WE
STAND IN UNITY WE STAND NOT TO.
DIVIDE AND IT JUST FEELS A-
BOMB. AT THAT I AM PROUD TO
STAND WITH THAT CENTER
ARCHULETA TODAY AND I'M PROUD
TO STAND WITH ANYBODY. WHO HAS
SERVED THIS COUNTRY. AND
DESERVES A LITTLE BIT OF
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU SENATOR
AIKMAN SAID AWAY SO. THANK YOU.
HELLO ARE THERE CAN I OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW I
JUST WANTED TO RISE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE COMMENTS WERE MADE
ABOUT BEING INCLUDED IN THE MID
IN MILITARY SERVICE AND NOT
SEGREGATED I THINK THAT REALLY
DOES NOT DO SERVICE TO WHAT
REALLY HAS HAPPENED IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY DESPITE. OF
THE- HISPANICS AND LATINOS
SERVING. IN IN MILITARY IN THE
MILITARY AND BEING INTEGRATED
THIRTY EIGHT THEY SUFFERED
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RACISM. IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA
INCLUDING BEING PASSED UP FOR
IMPORTANT METALS AND PROMOTIONS
RIGHT NOW THE LARGEST GROWING
ETHNIC GROUP IN THE MILITARY
ARE ARE LATINOS AND LATINO
ORIGIN. YET THEY ARE NOT
ACHIEVING RANK AT THE SAME
LEVEL AS OTHER ETHNIC GROUPS
AND THAT CALLS INTO QUESTION IN
TERMS OF HOW. OUR MILITARY IS
BEING RUN. AND WHETHER LATINOS
ARE GIVING- ARE BEING GIVEN A
FAIR OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN
POSITIONS OF RANK IN POSITIONS
OF LEADERSHIP. IN OUR MILITARY
WE KNOW THAT THAT HAS HAPPENED.
HISTORICALLY AND WE NEED TO
RAISE AWARENESS THAT THAT IS
HAS HAPPENED AND THAT IT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN WITHIN THE
RANKS OF OUR MILITARY. BUT
THERE'S A DIFFERENT STORY TO BE
TOLD ABOUT LATINO SERVING IN IN
IN THE MILITARY THERE'S A VERY
IMPORTANT STORY TO BE TOLD
ABOUT NATIVE AMERICANS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND ASIAN
AMERICANS ALL OF THEM HAVE
PROVIDED. A UNIQUE ADVANTAGE IN
THE AREA OF IN IT INTERNATIONAL
CAMP- CAMPAIGNS ARE TO KEEP OUR
COUNTRY SAFE AND KEEP OUR
COUNTRY ON TOP IN TERMS OF
MILITARY MIGHT AND POWER. AND
I'M NOT AFRAID OF US
UNDERSTANDING THAT IF THERE IS
A STORY TO BE TOLD AND YOU
SHOULD BE TOLD. AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID OF THAT
STORY. ON UNITING US THAT'S NOT
THE POINT THE POINT IS TO
RAISE. AWARENESS ABOUT LATINOS
HAVING HAD CONTRIBUTED. TO
MAKING THIS COUNTRY GREAT DON'T
BE AFRAID OF RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT. LATINOS HAVE
MADE AND DON'T BE AFRAID OF
RECOGNIZING THE CONTRIBUTION
CONTRIBUTION THAT EVERYONE HAS
MADE. AND THIS IS NOT AN EFFORT
TO DENY BUT TO TELL THE STORY
AND TO REALLY LOOK AT A GROUP
THAT. HAS DISTINGUISHES ITSELF
FROM MILITARY SERVICE TODAY IN
IN WORLD WAR TWO
PROPORTIONATELY. ONE OF THE%
MOST. RECOGNIZED GROUPS IN
TERMS OF VALOR AND MEDALS OF
VALOR HAVE BEEN LATINOS EVEN IF
THEY WERE PASSED OVER FOR
IMPORTANT RECOGNITIONS THEY
STILL DOMINATED IN THE AREA OF
VALOR AND MAKING THE ULTIMATE
THIS COUNTRY THAT NEEDS TO BE
TOLD THAT HISTORY CANNOT BE
FORGOTTEN. AND I PRAISE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR HIS MILITARY
SERVICE AND FOR HIS SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY. IN A VERY
DISTINGUISHED WAY. HISTORY
NEEDS TO BE TOLD TO SELL I
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
SENT AWAY SO BUT SENATOR DRAWS
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS- RIGHT NOW
THERE IS A GENTLEMAN OF
VETERAN. SOMEONE PASTORAL WHO'S
WALKING THE BORDER TO RAISE THE
ISSUE. OF IMMIGRANTS ESPECIALLY
LATINO IMMIGRANT VETERANS WHO
HAVE BEEN DEPORTED. IMAGINE
THAT. VETERANS WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES SACRIFICED THEIR
LIVESSACRIFICED EVERYTHING FOR
THIS NATION AND THEY'RE
DEPORTED. THAT IS WHAT IS STILL
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE TO STAND UP
AND RAISE THE ISSUE SUCH AS THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE IN A VERY
RESPECTFUL WAY WITH THIS NATION
FOR THIS COUNTRY THAT WE ALL
LOVE. WE STILL HAVE TO RAISE
THESE ISSUES AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO NOT TREAT ANYBODY LESS
THAN ANYBODY ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SAID ARCHER ARCHER LET YOU MAKE
CLOTHES I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
FELLOW SENATORS FOR STANDING UP.
AND I WILL SHARE A LITTLE BIT I
DON'T KNOW IF SOME OF YOU KNOW
OR MAY NOT KNOW I WAS A
PRESIDENTIAL APPOINTEE TO THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY ACADEMY
AT WEST POINT. APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA. WHEN I WAS
SENT THERE HE SAID LET'S MAKE
WEST POINT LOOK LIKE AMERICA
WHEN I GOT THERE IT SURELY
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE AMERICA I
ASKED THE THREE STAR GENERAL
THE SUPERINTENDENT. GENERAL WHY
AREN'T THERE ANY LATINOS
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION WHY AREN'T
THE NCOS NONCOMMISSIONED
OFFICERS WHO ARE TRAINING THESE
CADETS WHY ARE NIGHT ARE THEY
NOT COMING FROM ACROSS AMERICA
YES I DON'T SEE A DOLLAR TO GO
MRS SANCHEZ. OR WILLIAMS. OR
JOHNSON I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON SO WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE
THIS SO OVER TIME IT HAS
CHANGED AND JUST RECENTLY. WEST
POINT GRADUATE THE LARGEST
CONTINGENT OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN IN HISTORY WE'RE ON THE
WAY. MY TWO SONS SERVED AT WEST
POINT. BOTH WON A CLASS
PRESIDENT WANT TO GE- A CLASS
PRESIDENT FOUR YEARS APART. THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND I HAVE A NEPHEW AT
WEST POINT RIGHT NOW. AND HE
WAS GIVEN THE TASK OF SERVING
WITH THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE
DURING THE SUMMER BREAK. AND
WHAT HE'S TOLD ME IS THAT A
KEBAB. YOU KNOW I WAS THERE AT
FORT BRAGG NORTH CAROLINA.
TENET AND I LOOKED AROUND AND I
WAS AMAZED AT THE NUMBER OF
LATINO PARATROOPERS THAT WERE
IN THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE.
WOW THEY COME FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
I SAID YOU JUST CONTINUE YOUR
JOB. IN ONE DAY MAYBE YOU'LL
JUMP ON AIRPLANES TO LIKE OLD
UNCLE BOB. BUT I WILL TELL YOU
THIS LADIES IN GERMAN. IF YOU
HEARD THE RESOLUTION I SAID
SIXTY CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF
HONOR. THAT MEANS THAT GOD
ALMIGHTY HOW MANY LOST THEIR
LIVES ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CALL
OF DUTY. WE'RE ONLY ASKING FOR
RESIGNATION OF RECOGNITION OF
SEPTEMBER THE TWENTIETH. WE'RE
ASKING FOR RECOGNITION
RECOGNITION OF THOSE LATINOS
WHO SERVED MEN AND WOMEN. WHO
NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
SERVICE. THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAY
THANK YOU. AND MY SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT I'VE HEARD THE STORY.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE MEN WHO ARE
IN MEXICO RIGHT NOW WHO ARE
TRYING TO COME BACK TO AMERICA
IF THEY WERE DEPORTED.
HONORABLY DISCHARGED YET
DEPORTED WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT WE'VE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING SO MANY THINGS
THE EQUALIZE THINGS. IN THIS
RESOLUTION WILL START. SO MADAM
PRESIDENT I ASK FOR NOVEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA R. I.
ATKINS I FACE I BACKER. I
FORGES HI BRADFORD I HAVE I HAD
A- I CORTESE FIVE DALLY I DON
HI THERE ALSOHI AIKMAN I LASER
EYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE FIVE
HURTS BERG I WAS SO SORRY FOR
TIDO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
MCCOY- I MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN. A TELEVOTE
I PAN FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE
STERN I AM BERG HI WHITE HOUSE
V. I. WINNER. WELK PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. NIELSEN I.
WEINER WELL HI. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT WHO KNOWS ONE THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX SENATOR PAM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE
BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO THE
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT SENATOR PAM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT S. C. R.
FIFTY ONE RECOGNIZING THE
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICTS TWENTY THIRTY ZERO
CARBON EMISSIONS GOAL WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN APRIL TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
THINK AS WE LOOK ABOUT US WE
SEE THE WILD FIRES WE THINK
ABOUT THE TEMPERATURES THAT WE
EXPERIENCE THIS WEEKEND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE ACTUALLY THINK
HIT THEIR SECOND HIGHEST
TEMPERATURE. ON RECORD DOWNTOWN
CHECK ABOUT A HUNDRED THIRTEEN
DEGREES WE LOOK AT THE IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WE HAVE BEEN
STEPPING UP TO SAY THAT. WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE HERE
IN CAIFORNIA BUT ALSO WHAT'S
REALLY ALSO IMPORTANT IN
ADDITION TO THE POLICIES THAT
WE HAVE PASSED HERE IT RAN THIS
VERY CHAMBER TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE WE AS A STATE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HERE WE ARE IN
THE CAPITAL WE HAVE STREET
STATE OFFICES THROUGHOUT THIS
REGION AND ACROSS THE STATE THE
STATE ITSELF ALSO NEEDS TO TAKE
A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN SHOWING
OTHER EMPLOYERS HOW TO MINIMIZE
OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT IN
ADDITION HERE IN OUR STATE
CAPITAL I KNOW THAT WE'VE TAKEN
STEPS A. AND I REMEMBER- OUR
GOOD FRIEND FROM BERKELEY MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM BERKELEY AND
HER LEADERSHIP ROLE AND
GETTING- ADDRESSING ISSUES HERE
TO CAPITAL ON TERMS OF ALSO
REDUCING OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
OF OUR STATE CAPITAL BUT THE
UNDERLYING ALL OF THIS IS THE
FACT THAT WE HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND OTHER VARIOUS
OFFICE BUILDINGS. ARE POWERED
BY THE SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT AND SO AS- THE
SENATOR REPRESENTING THIS AREA
I'M PARTICULARLY PROUD SMUD IS
EFFECTUALLY NO IT. HAS DECLARED
THAT IT WILL BE THE FIRST.
FIRST LARGE UTILITY TO AID TO
TRY TO ACHIEVE ZERO CARBON
EMISSIONS AND TO HIT IT BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THAT THIS THE
BODIES THAT SMILE WILL PLAY ITS
PART IN ITS ROLE ENSURING THAT
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT IN OUR
STATE. THE TRI CITY IF ITS
CLIMATE GOALS SO S. E. R. FIFTY
pSPIRIT COMMITMENT. TO OUR
BUYERS POWER SUPPLIERS TO
ACHIEVE A ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
THAT DOES NOT COMPROMISE
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
AS WELL. SO I HOPE THAT I CAN
COUNT ON YOUR VOTE FOR S.
YOU'RE FIFTY ONE WHICH
RECOGNISES MUD FOR SETTING THE
MOST AMBITIOUS GOAL OF ZERO
CARBON EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND BE THE FIRST OF ANY
LARGE UTILITY IN THE COUNTRY
AND DOING SO ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN
I VOTE AND RECOGNIZING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ACHIEVEMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MATT THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I. I MUST RISE AND THEN
LET THE MEMBERS KNOW I WHEN I
CAME TO THE SENATE SEAT I
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS A SMART AND
I. HAPPEN TO BE A CUSTOMER AS
WELL. AND THEY SHOULD THEY GOT
WITH ME AND TALKED ABOUT THEIR
TWENTY THIRTY PLAN. AND SO THE
pREAD THROUGH THE PLAN AND I
WANT TO. SHARE WITH YOU I WILL
BE OPPOSING THIS. RESOLUTION
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO RAISE. RATES AND- THEY
JUST RAISE RATES IN ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH THE RATES WENT UP AS
A SMART CUSTOMERS. THE
COMMODITY COSTS ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE FROM ABOUT SIXTYMILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TO MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. MILLION BY TWENTY
THIRTY. A SEVEN HUNDRED AND 50%
INCREASE. THAT'S MUCH PLANS TO
PAY FOR THIS. WITH COUNTLESS
UNKNOWING FUNDING STREAMS. SOME
OF THOSE ARE GOVERNMENT
POLICIES I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS GRANTS THAT MEANS THAT
SOMEBODY'S TAXPAYER MONEY'S
GOING TO GO TO IT. INVESTOR
RELATIONSHIPS I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THAT MEANS AS WELL. TECHNOLOGY
SAVINGS FOR UNPROVEN THINGS
LIKE LARGE BATTERY STORAGE. SO
THERE'S GOING TO BE A COST TO
THE RATE PAYERS AND- AS I'VE
SAID MANY TIMES ON THIS FLOOR
THAT THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE
ZERO. EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY WAS **** IS GOING TO BE
A HUGE IMPACT ON THE RATE
PAYERS AND THIS IS A PLAN
THAT'S NOT VERY WELL THOUGHT
THOUGHT OUT IN MY OPINION SO.
THE ONE THING WE CAN WE CAN
COUNT ON IS THAT. THE RATE
PAYERS WILL BE ON THE HOOK AT
THE END. AND WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAT BUT BEFORE GOING INTO IT
SO FOR THOSE REASONS. I OPPOSE
S. C. R. FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY CENTER BECKER.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. IN THE GLOBAL
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE WE
NEED MODELS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE
DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS SO
IMPORTANT. WHAT WE DO ON
TRANSPORTATION WHAT WE DO ON
THE GRID. BUT WHAT WE DO ON-
THE BUILDINGS WILL BE DO YOU ON
CEMENT. WE COULDN'T CREATE
MODELS FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. AND IN MANY CASES REST
THE WORLD SO I JUST WANNA
COMMAND. THE AUTHOR ADMIN
COMMANDS BUT THE SURGE THIS
MONTH IS A TREMENDOUS. GOAL TO
BE ZERO CARBON BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
KIND OF POLICY FOR A LONG TIME.
THE CLEAR MARKET PLACE
CONFERENCE WE START FOR EPA
NINETEEN NINETY ONE. WE ALWAYS
KNEW AT THE TIME THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY. WASN'T POSSIBLE AT
THAT TIME TO GET. TO ZERO BUT
NOW WE KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY IS
THERE. BUT WE HAVE. THE
CAPACITY WITH RENEWABLES WITH
YOUR THERMAL WITH OFFSHORE
WIND. WITH ALL THE OTHER NEW
TECHNOLOGY COMING ONLINE WE
KNOW WE CAN GET THERE WE KNOW
WE CAN ACHIEVE. THIS YOUR CAR
BY TWENTY THIRTY GOAL IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND I. HAVE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER GROVE. AND PRESIDENT I
TOO HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THE DETAILS- WHAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS. BUT
I ALSO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SILICON VALLEY. AND HE
SAYS THAT YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO OUT THERE MAKES A
HUGE DIFFERENCE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
SAY THIS BODY IS THAT. MY
DISTRICT PRODUCES 53% OF ALL
SOLAR ENERGY RENEWABLE ENERGY
TO THE GRID AND SO WHILE MY
DISTRICT IS BUILDING LARGE
SCALE SOLAR PLANTS WITH NO TAX
BENEFITS IS A MATTER OF FACT
WE'VE LOST A HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR FIREFIGHTERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT- ALL OF THOSE
THINGS IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
SO WHAT WE SEND OUR ENERGY
SOLAR ENERGY NORTH. POSSIBLY
THIS MAN I'M TRYING TO GET A
TEXT BACK IMMEDIATELY BUT I
KNOW IT DOES GO TO SACRAMENTO
WHEN IT DOES GO TO SAN
FRANCISCO WHEN IT DOES GO TO
LOS ANGELES. AS A MATTER OF
FACT LOS ANGELES PUTS THEIR
COMMERCIALS UP ON TV AND
THEY'RE USING OUR SOLAR. LARGE
SCALE SOLAR FACILITIES M.
PLANTS- IN KERN COUNTY IN PART
OF THEIR- ADVERTISING THIS IS
THAT WE'VE GOT THEM ON A GREEN
TECHNOLOGY. NOT BELIEVE THAT'S
THAT LOS ANGELES IS ON A GREEN
TECHNOLOGY A PLATFORM. WELL
THAT ENERGY IS COMING FROM KERN
COUNTY SO- YOU KNOW WHEN I
DON'T SEE SOLAR PLANTS IN
INGLEWOOD AND I DON'T SEE SOLAR
PLANTS IN SACRAMENTO AND I
DON'T SEE LARGE SCALE SOLAR IN
ANY OTHER REALLY PARTS OF THE
STATE- I JUST YOU KNOW THINK
THAT YOU GUYS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS AGAIN OF APPROVING
A SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATT POWER PLANT. AND I'M
ASKING MY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS NOT TO APPROVE THAT
PLAN. DON'T APPROVE IT IF WE'RE
NOT GONNA GET ANY BENEFITS OUT
OF IT WHATSOEVER AND IT'S GONNA
DO NOTHING BUT A CHIEF OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS
THAT ARE BY THIS GOVERNOR IN
THIS. MAJORITY BODY THAT- WE
SHOULD HOLD OUT YOU KNOW HOLD
TIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN THE HIGH
ROAD WE HAVE TAKEN THE HIGH
ROAD AND- WE HAVE PRODUCED 53%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND WE GET ZERO CREDIT
FOR IT WHATSOEVER AND THEN WE
PRODUCE 70% OF THE STATE'S OIL
AND WE GET ATTACKED ON THAT ON
A DAILY BASIS. SO MAKING SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA BEACHES
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS BY THE
DATE THAT THIS. RESOLUTION IS
SET THAT'S MADE HIS AGREED TO.
A KERN COUNTY IS A BIG PART OF
THAT AND I THINK WE SHOULD
TALK. BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO THAT- THE NEXT
SOLAR PLANT IT'S POSSIBLY A
HOPEFULLY NOT APPROVED. IN THE
NEAR FUTURE THAT WE HOLD OFF ON
IT- IS UP FIVE TIMES THE SIZE
OF DISNEYLAND IT WILL PRODUCE
ANOTHER SIX THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF POWER.
GREEN ENERGY. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS PIECE THIS
RESOLUTION AND I ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIEBER. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR PAN
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE SMARTEST
MENISCAL UTILITY THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ARE ELECTED BY THE
PEOPLE SO I'M PROUD THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE IN SUPPORT. I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT-
ACTUALLY POWER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IS LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN MANY OF THE SURROUNDING
AREAS- BECAUSE I DO HAVE PARTS
OF MY DISTRICT AREN'T. COVERED
BY SMUD. AND HEAR ABOUT POWER
COSTS- THERE AS WELL SO- I
THINK CMOS PROVE THEMSELVES
RELIABLE HATING THE PROVEN
THEMSELVES TO BE COST
EFFECTIVE- THEY HAVE A GOOD
PLAN TO ACHIEVE TWENTY THIRTY
ZERO CARB MISSIONS I SHOULD
ALSO POINT OUT. IN TERMS OF
SOLAR IF YOU GO TO SACRAMENTO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AND YOU
KNOW MANY OF YOU FLY OUT OF
THAT AIRPORT TO GO HOME. PLEASE
NOTE THE SOLAR FARM THAT'S ON
THE AIRPORT- SO WE CERTAINLY
HAVE SOLAR HERE BUT CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
PARTS OF OUR STATE THAT ALSO
ENGAGED IN SOLAR. AND PROVIDING
SOLAR POWER SO WE CAN HAVE A
MORE RENEWABLE FUTURE HERE IN
THE TIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SAYS ONLY ONE APPRECIATE. THAT
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE ARE
ALSO DOING THEIR SHARE BUT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM
THANK YOU. THE CENTER PANEL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BECKER FIVE
FORGES BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY NO DODD. HI
TORONTO I A GIVEN HI BLAZER
FIVE TEN DOLLARS FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
MEG WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A CHILL OF
BOTH. PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I
ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
STERN I AM BERG HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WINNER WELL. PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. EIGHT FOR
JUST. JONES MELINDA'S. CONTROL
OF BOTH. WINNER WELL. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NEWS TO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
REMAIN THE FINAL ITEM FORTY
SEVEN SENATOR MCGUIRE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PARKS AND RECREATION
PROFESSIONALS MONTH SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESIDENT IN GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS UP PLEASE BE A PRISON
S. HERE FIFTY TWO WHICH
RECOGNIZES THIS BEAUTIFUL MONTH
OF JULY AS A CALIFORNIA PARK
AND RECREATION PROFESSIONALS A
MONTH. WE HAVE TO BE HONEST
WITH EACH OTHER WE LOVE OUR
STATE NATIONAL AND LOCAL PARKS
AS CALIFORNIANS THEY CONNECT US
TO NATURE AND OPEN SPACE IN
ARTS. IN ITS THOSE PARK AND
RECREATION PROFESSIONALS WHO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
ENJOY OUR PARKS IN THE MANY
RECREATIONAL SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE THEY LITERALLY MAINTAIN
MILLIONS OF ACRES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE AND WHEN KOBE
NINETEEN HIT PARKS AND
RECREATION PROFESSIONALS
STEPPED UP LIKE NEVER BEFORE
CONVERTING THEIR FACILITIES
INTO COPING NINETEEN TESTING
CENTERS IN. VACCINATION SITES
IN WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT PARKS
PARKS BECAME MORE IMPORTANT TO
THE GOLDEN STATE THAN EVER
BEFORE DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT
THEY WORK TIRELESSLY FOR THE
PUBLIC AND THAT IS WHY HONORED
TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS THE
CALIFORNIA PARKS AND RECREATION
PROFESSIONALS MONTH WOULD BE
HONORED IF THE STATE DID SO THE
SENATE DID SO AS WELL WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
MONTHS. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR OCHO VOGUE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
FIFTY TO. OUR STATE AND LOCAL
PARKS ARE BELOVED BY MANY
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE OUR
COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO OPEN
SPACE ANY NATURE. STEVE ARGUE
THAT A SPACE WHERE THEY CAN
SAFELY ENGAGE IN PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES LIKE RUNNING HIKING
SKATEBOARDING AND PLAYING
SPORTS WHICH BENEFIT BOTH THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT IS WHY I'M SO GRATEFUL TO
YOU AND PART OF SUPPORTER OF
OUR PARKS AND RECREATION
PROFESSIONALS. WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
SERVING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THESE PROFESSIONALS ARE
CRITICAL TO MAINTAINING OUR
PUBLIC LANDS AS WELL AS
PROVIDING EDUCATION ON HOW WE
CAN BEST PRESERVE AND PROTECT
OPEN SPACES. THAT ALLOW US TO
CONNECT WITH NATURE AND ENJOY
THE OUTDOORS. THE SWIFT ACTION
OF THESE EMPLOYEES DURING THE
CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
INSURE THAT PARKS WE MADE A
SAFE AND HEALTHY SPACE FOR
PEOPLE TO GO OUTDOORS AND
RECEIVE SOME MUCH NEEDED. WE
SPIED FROM LOCKDOWNS. TO ALL OF
OUR PARKS AND RECREATION
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR OTOBO MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. CENTER WHERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE THANK YOU SIR AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SO SORRY MEMBERS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU DENNIS RODMAN
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION SEEING AND
HEARING THEM I WAS THIRTY NINE
WHO KNOWS ZERO. THE RESOLUTION%
IS ADOPTED MEMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
CABALLERO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR KABBADI
AUTO RELATIVE TO MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING. THE CALERO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SR FORTY ONE WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A MEANINGFUL AND
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE BETWEEN
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
MOTORCYCLE RIDING COMMUNITY.
AND LOCAL AND STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AROUND THE
ISSUE OF MOTORCYCLE PROFILING
THIS RESOLUTION URGES LOCAL AND
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO INCLUDE STATEMENTS
CONDEMNING MOTORCYCLE PROFILING
IN WRITTEN POLICIES AND
TRAINING MATERIALS. ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING SURVEY THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF REPORTED INCIDENTS
OF AN UNLAWFUL DETENTION BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR REASONS
UNRELATED TO TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS
IN MANY CASES WRITERS WERE
PLACED IN HANDCUFFS WERE
ORDERED TO SIT. OR LAY ON THE
GROUND WHILE OFFICERS SEARCHED
THE CLOTHING OR MOTORCYCLES OR
FIELD INFORMATION CARDS WERE
USED TO COLLECT INFORMATION
ABOUT WRITERS THAT WERE LATER
TURNED OVER TO GANG UNIT
OFFICERS. WERE IT WAS USED TO
DOCUMENT ASSOCIATIONS OR ADD
NAMES TO THE CAL GAME STATE
DATABASE WITHOUT ANY
JUSTIFICATION IN THE SAME
SURVEY 50% OF THE WRITERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE SURVEY
REPORTED THEY BELIEVE THEY WERE
PULLED OVER SIMPLY FOR RIDING A
MOTORCYCLE OR FOR WEARING MOTOR
MOTORCYCLE RELATED CLOTHING OR
COLORS. ANY STATES INCLUDING
MARYLAND LOUISIANA AND IDAHO
HAVE PASSED LAWS TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. IT IS TIME TO BEGIN
A DIALOGUE AND PLAN STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND THIS
RESOLUTION SIMPLY URGES THAT
ALL PARTIES HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NEIGHBOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
MEMBERS AS ANY OBJECTION TO USE
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE SENATOR
ROTH MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ROTH RELATIVE
TO PUBLIC SAFETY SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES THE 20% TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY RATHER OF A
NONPROFIT. FIGHT CRIME INVEST
IN KIDS AND EXPRESSES GRATITUDE
FOR ITS CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
WELL BEING. OF ALL THE CHIDREN
OF THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS MEMBERS HAVE
CHAMPIONED ISSUES CREATING
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC POLICY
CHANGE. THERE ARE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
INCREASED INVESTMENTS IN AFTER
SCHOOL AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND TO
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS
PLAYED AN INTEGRAL PART IN THE
SUCCESSFUL PACKED PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FORTY NINE. THE
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION AND
SAFETY ACT WHICH HELPED CREATE
OVER TWO THOUSAND NEW AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
MEMBERS OF THIS ORGANIZATION IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY HAVE
CREATED AND CONTINUE TO BUILD
ON THE SUCCESS WITH ADVOCACY
FOR SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
CHILD CARE FOR PRESCHOOLAND
AFTER PROGRAMS. FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS HAS BEEN AN
ANNUAL VOICE OF THE CAPITAL
TESTIFYING IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND MEETINGS WITH
LEGISLATORS TO ADVOCATE FOR
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. WE HAVE AN INVOICE
FOR THE POWER THAT INVESTMENTS
IN PRESCHOOL CHILD CARE AND
AFTER SCHOOL CAN HAVE ON
IMPACTING FAMILIES LIVES PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES IN THE
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENTS FOR
OUR CHILDREN. PLEASE HELP ME
CONGRATULATE FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS WHEN IT'S TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY AS
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL
EYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
REMOVING TWO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
SENATOR CORTESE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACT
RELATING RELATING TO RETIREMENT
AS A WOMAN SKEWS ME SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
ROSE 2% E. B. FORTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AS A MEMBER ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD CREATE A TEMPORARY
REFUNDABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
CERTAIN PUBLIC FRONT LINE
WORKERS THE COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED ILLNESS. PRESUMED TO BE
CONTRACTED ON THE JOB SHE'LL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR DISABILITY
RETIREMENT. THESE EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. FIREFIGHTERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
TO NAME A FEW. MAYBE EIGHT
FORTY FIVE AM FINANCIALLY
PROTECT THOSE WILL HELP KEEP
OUR LIGHTS ON. THE WATER
RUNNING OR FOOD STOCKS INTRUDER
ILLNESSES WALLS OR LOVED ONES
IN THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE'RE STILL DISCOVERING THE
EFFECTS. OF LONG HAUL YOU
QUOTATIONS IN THE VERY LEAST WE
CAN DO IS ASSIST THOSE WHO
SURPRISED PROVIDED FOR US.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN PROTECTING
THESE WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SENATORCORTESE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING
AND HEARING THEM EYES THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE SENATOR
PORTENT TINO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIN SIGN AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE PEOPLE
HEALTH AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SIX THIRTY
MINUTE LENGTH. CENTERPOINT TINA
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW COVER
NINETEEN IS UPENDED IN CHANGED
EVERYONE'S LIFE EVERYDAY LIFE.
THIS DEADLY VIRUS ALSO HAD THE
POTENTIAL FOR SHORT AND LONG
TERM ADVERSE ADVERSE HEALTH
IMPACTS ON OUR YOUTH. WHO MAY
HAVE CONTRACTED COVEN NINETEEN
YOUTH ANOTHER HEALTHY STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED OR TESTED
POSITIVE FOR CARBON NINETEEN
MAY NOT KNOW OF THE POTENTIAL
HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED. WITH
ENGAGING IN PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
WHICH INCLUDE SEVEN SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH AMONG
STUDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
AV EIGHT FIVE SIX WOULD DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE POST AN INFORMATION SHEET
ON THE DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE FOR
PUPILS STATING THE CURRENT CODE
NINETEEN HEALTH RISKS AND A
GRADUAL RETURN TO PHYSICAL
EXERCISE GUIDELINES SET BY THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO DISTRIBUTE
THIS INFORMATIONAL FACT SHEET
THE PARENTS AND STUDENTS
THROUGH VARIOUS MEANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE UP.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTENT TINO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
pDEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM EYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY FIVE THIRTY NINE DOES
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
TWO SO FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
AN ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EMPLOYEES SENATOR
NEWMAN. SAID THANK YOU AT
PRESENT GOOD AFTERNOON MISS. A
MEMBERS TODAY ARISE RESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN FIVE A.
B. TWO SEVEN FIVE WOULD REDUCE.
THE MAXIMUM PROBATIONARY PERIOD
FOR ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
NON MERIT DISTRICTS. FROM ONE
YEAR TO SIX MONTHS OR ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY DAYS OF PAID
SERVICE WHICHEVER IS LONGER. IN
NON MERIT DISTRICTS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES HAVE A ONE YEAR
MAXIMUM PROBATIONARY PERIOD
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN MERRITT
DISTRICTS HAVE THE MAXIMUM OF
SIX MONTHS OF PROBATION. THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE OF PROBATION
PERIOD FOR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES IS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE
TO PERFORM THE DUTIES OF THEIR
POSITION TO THE SATISFACTION OF
THE EMPLOYER BEFORE GAINING
PERMIT STATUS. INCLUDING DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS IF A PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION PROCESSES PROPERLY
UTILIZED A SIX MONTH PROBATION
PERIOD PROVIDES MORE THAN
ENOUGH TIME FOR MANAGEMENT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER AN EMPLOYEE.
HAS MET THEIR STANDARDS
BRINGING PARITY TO THE NON
MERIT COMMUNITY COLLEGES SIX
WILL NOT COMPROMISE. THE
QUALITY OF THE WORK PERFORMED.
THEY'RE MAKING THIS PAPER
THINNER AND THINNER EVERY YEAR
TWO YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED AB THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
WHICH REDUCED THE PROBATION
PERIOD FOR K. TWELVE CLASSROOM
EMPLOYEES. WORKING IN NON MERIT
TO SIX FROM ONE YEAR TO SIX
MONTHS IN ALIGNMENT WITH K.
TWELVE CLASS WRITING PLEASE.
WORKING IN MERRITT DISTRICTS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASS WRITING
PLEASE WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS WERE INADVERTENTLY
LEFT OUT. THIS BILL REMEDIES
THAT OVERSIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WITH ALAN I ARCHULETA I
AT KINS FIVE EIGHTHS. BECKER
FIVE FOUR JUST NO BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM FIVE CORTESE I
DALLY. NO DODD. I- ALSO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I
GROW. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
I- TIDO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER
FIVE LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. NO MAN
HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO BUT SHOW
A VOGUE. NO PAN HI FOURTEEN
TINA. I. ROSS HI RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER FIVE STERN FIVE AMBERG
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER.
WELL NO PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. FACE NO WEINER. FIVE
TWENTY NINE NEWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
TWO SENATOR RUBIO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER CHEAP TREATMENT.
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY ONE I'M A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ARE
MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY TO
SMOKE CIGARETTES THE MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM TOBACCO
RELATED ILLNESSES EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY ONE WILL REQUIRE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROGRAMS
TO ASSESS ALL PATIENTS FOR
TOBACCO USE. AND OFFER
TREATMENT OR A REFERRAL TO
TREATMENT TO TACKLE ARE BOTH
ISSUES THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS. AND SUPPORTED BY
A WIDE COALITION OF HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT NOT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING THAT NICE
THIRTY NINE OH ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE SILL DO HAVE
A COUPLE BILLS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE VOTING ON BUT WE ARE
GOING TO AT THIS TIME TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS IS THE TIME TO DO
IT. SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ALL
THE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILLS AT.
611-938-4966 EIGHTY SEVEN FOUR
FOURTEEN AND ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION NINE. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN ADOPTED OKAY MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX. SENATOR RUBIO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AN ACT RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AT SIX THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH BUILDS UPON LAST YEAR'S
STRIDES IN MENTAL HEALTH BY
AUTHORIZING COUNTIESTO INCLUDE
IN THEIR PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. COMPONENT MENTAL
HEALTH AS WELL AS SUBSTANCE
MISUSE OR CORKER IN SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER DURING THE TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD BETWEEN JUNE
TWENTY NINETEEN AND JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WERE AT LEAST
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR OVERDOSE DEATHS.
ACCIDENTAL DRUG OVERDOSES
KILLED TWICE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
CAR ACCIDENTS UNFORTUNATELY THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
AFFECTED CHILDREN AND ADULTS IN
UNPRECEDENTED WAYS THAT
INCLUDES DEVELOPING ANXIETY
DEPRESSION ISOLATION AND
FEELING. OF DESPAIR AS WELL AS
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS BEST POSITIONED
TO PROVIDE EDUCATION AND
PREVENTION PROGRAMS TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS IN THE V. EIGHT A
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT WAS
ALREADY GREATLY IMPACTED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. RECENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AT A CO
AUTHORS IT MADE WHAT TECHNICAL
CHANGE THINKING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SITTING IN
HER NO NICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
SENATOR DOLLY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND ACT RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD CODE.
CENTER CALLING THE MATTER
PRESENT MEMBERS EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE AS A COMMITTEE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
RETAIL FOOD IS SAFETY COALITION
WHICH MAKES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD CODE. HI
SPEC THEY ASKED FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALI MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SENIOR
HEARING NONE I'M SORRY NINE
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
THAT WAS OUR LAST BILL THE DAY
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO COMMITTEE
S. ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
ENERGY UTILITIES COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE IS MEETING HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER UPON
ADJOURNMENT THANK YOU SENATOR
WAY SO. SENATOR CORTESE DID YOU
WANT TO ANNOUNCE YOUR COMMITTEE.
FOR SENATOR PORTENT TINO CENTER
CORTESE DID YOU WANNA ANNOUNCER
COMMITTEE. YES A LIVE
REPUBLICAN EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
THE CONCLUSION OF THE SENATE OF
THIS SESSION IN ROOM FOR TWO OR
THREE THANK YOU SANDER CORTESE
CENTER PARDON TINO- THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WILL MEET IMMEDIATELY AFTER
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. THANK YOU CENTERPOINT
TINO. ON. JUST TO BE CLEAR
LABOUR MEETS UPON ADJOURNMENT
OF APPROPRIATIONS OKAY MEMBERS
WE'RE NOW MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THAT
THIS WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR A JOURNEY IN MEMORIES
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF CREE LAY A FOUNDING
FATHER OF CAMBODIAN IMMIGRATION
AND SUPPORT IN LONG BEACH
GREAT- CREE LAKE WAS BORN ON
DECEMBER TENTH NINETEEN FORTY
ONE AND OO DHAN CAMBODIA AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE SHE WAS ORDAINED
AS ABUDDHIST AND SERVED AS A
MONK FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS
WHILE PURSUING HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE IN INDIA THE BRUTAL
COMMUNIST REGIME OF MY ROUGE
TOOK OVER CAMBODIA THE TAKEOVER
CURTAILED HIS STUDIES AND LED
HIM TO SEEK ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES. PLACE SETTLED IN
LONG BEACH IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WITH HIS WIFE FUNCIONA
WHOM HE HAD MET IN INDIA THEY
RAISED THREE DAUGHTERS TOGETHER
PLAY PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN THE
FORMATION OF THE SOUTHEAST
ASIAN LEARNERS PROGRAM BUT IN
THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE HE DEVELOPED THE
BILLING GOLF BILINGUAL COMITE
IF ENGLISH CURRICULUM THAT
STILL LIVES ON TODAY. AS AN
EDUCATOR HE SERVED AS AN EXPERT
ON THE EDUCATION OF CAMBODIAN
REFUGEES INSPIRING THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANTS HELPING BRIDGE THE
CULTURAL GAP BETWEEN MY
STUDENTS AND THEIR NON
CAMBODIAN TEACHERS AND LAYING
THE FOUNDATION FOR LONG BEACH'S
CAMBODIAN CHILDREN TO FACT
THRIVED DECADES LATER HE ALSO
SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
CAMBODIAN ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA FOR OVER THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS. LEE DIED OF
COMPLICATIONS UNFORTUNATELY
FROM ALZHEIMER DISEASE ON JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTH AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY NINE HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS THREE DAUGHTERS CHAINED TO
DEAR MONICA AND HIS WIFE UP ON
SOONER. HIS SISTER LATE PM. IN
FOUR GRAND. AND NOT AND NIECES
HE'LL BE GREATLY MISSED BY ALL
WHO KNEW HIM. I WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED AS A LEGENDARY
EDUCATOR AND KAREN COMMUNITY
LEADER WHO HELPED THOUSANDS OF
CAMBODIAN REFUGEES. INTEGRATE
INTO LIFE IN LONG BEACH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY AND
OFFER OUR SINCEREST CONDOLENCES
TO THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY AND
ALL OF OUR LONG BEACH.
RESIDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER GONZALEZ PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME UP FORWARD SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE. NEXT WE'RE MOVING TO
SENATOR NIELSEN. RIGHT AND THEN
THE SENATE I WOULD ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY OF A
DEAR FRIEND AND LEADER. MANY
VAL OMIT MANDATE BACK IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES HE BECAME AN
APPOINTEE OF GOVERNOR BROWN. HE
HAD WORKED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND BECAME THE
DIRECTOR OF THAT DEPARTMENT. HE
JUST PASSED AWAY MAY THIRTY
FIRST THE- RIPE AGE OF NINETY
SEVEN. HE WAS A PURPLE HEART
BEDROOM AND RECEIVE THEIR
MEDALS FOR HIS SERVICE IN THE
MILITARY. THEY DEDICATED HIS
LIFE. TO THE MILITARY AND HIS
COLLEAGUES WITH WHOM WE SERVE.
THE MARRIAGE BRIDE LILY HAS A
BILL TO REPEAL THE PALLADIUM IN
LOS ANGELES AND THEY WERE
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX.
THEY THEN WENT TO WASHINGTON DC
HE ATTENDED THE AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY THEY'RE FURTHERING
HIS EDUCATION. HE WAS EMPLOYED
IN FORTY SEVEN BY THE DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS THEN HE
WORKED ON THE WAY THROUGH TO
THAT ORGANIZATION THE BEAT THE
STATE REHABILITATION DIRECT OR-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS SHE SERVED IN
MANY CAPACITIES AS I'VE NOTED
INCLUDING AS DIRECTOR OF THAT
DEPARTMENT. JESS UNRUH OUR
TREASURER AT THE TIME ALSO THEN
LATER APPOINTED HIM AS
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. THE ANY
ALSO WAS APPOINTED BY DID
NATION. TO THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT EXAMINERS.
BUT IF FOR SOME MIRACLE FORTY
YEARS GAVE OF HIMSELF. TO HIS
COMMUNITY TO HIS COUNTRY TO THE
STATE AND OF COURSE TO HIS
FELLOW VETERANS. AND GALLERY
TODAY THE DAUGHTER OF STEVEN
STEVEN DAUGHTER IN LAW KATHY
GRANDDAUGHTER. CHRISTINE AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND THAT'S
ELLA AND ABIGAIL AND JOE AND
TRACY COVERAGE. HE HASN'T
ENTERED AT THE ARLINGTON
MEMORIAL CEMETERY VERY JUSTLY
FOR THE CURTAIN KIND OF
CREDIBLE SERVICE THAT MANY
VALVES DEVOTED TO AMERICA AND
TO VETERANS I WOULD ASK THAT WE
ENTER AND THEN THE HONOR OF
MANY WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD TO THE BEACON PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM. SENATOR NEWMAN
AND CENTER NUMBER DID YOU WISH
TO PRESENT YOUR ATTORNEY
MEMORIES. SENATOR NEWMAN
PERCEIVED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF
MEDIA A GUIDE BY CLICKING
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF WALNUT
IN A LONG TIME NURSE AT QUEEN
OF THE VALLEY HOSPITAL THE CITY
WEST COVINA WHO PASSED AWAY
EARLIER THIS YEAR AFTER
CONTRACTING THE CORONA VIRUS IN
THE SERVICE OF THE PROFESSION
WHICH HE HAD MADE HER LIFE'S
WORK AMELIA. YEAH I WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT IN BY TECH
CITY IN THE PROVINCE OF ILOCOS
NORTE IN THE PHILIPPINES THE
YOUNGEST OF EIGHT SIBLINGS
AMELIA AND HIGH SCHOOL
SWEETHEART NESTOR BUCKLING
EMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR JOINING
A NEWS OTHER SIBLINGS IN HAWAII
AS EARLIER MEMBERS OF THEIR
EXTENDED FAMILY HAD DONE FOR
SUCCESSIVE GENERATIONS
BEGINNING WITH THEIR
GRANDFATHER WHO HAD BEEN ONE OF
THE FIRST FILIPINO FARMERS TO
MIGRATE. TO HAWAII FROM THE
PHILIPPINES TO WORK THE FIELDS
THERE A MILLION AND NESTOR
MARRIED THAT SAME YEAR IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THERE SURE
JOURNEY TO AMERICA BROUGHT THEM
HERE TO CALIFORNIA SINCE
CHILDHOOD AMELIA BARTLETT HAD
DREAMED OF BECOMING A NURSE SHE
COMPLETED HER INITIAL TRAINING
BEFORE IMMIGRATING FROM THE
PHILIPPINES. AND AFTER THE
COUPLE MOVED US INTO HEIGHTS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MEDIA TOOK
AND PASSED THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
LICENSURE EXAMINATION TO BE
ACCREDITED AS A REGISTERED
NURSE IN THE UNITED STATES
GAINING EMPLOYMENT SOON
THEREAFTER AS A LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSE AT QUEEN OF
THE VALLEY HOSPITAL. AVEENO
TWENTY EIGHT WILLIAM BUCKLEY
WORKED IN TIRELESS AS IF MEMBER
OF THE NURSE STAFF QUEEN OF TE
VALLEY STEADILY GAINING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING
CERTIFICATIONS AND SENIORITY AS
A NIGHT NURSE SHE TOOK GREAT
PRIDE IN CARING FOR HER
PATIENTS AND HER COLLEAGUES
EARNING HER THE NICKNAME MAMA
AMY AS SHE WAS KNOWN FIRST TO
THOSE WITH WHOM SHE WORKED AND
EVENTUALLY WITHIN THE LARGER
COMMUNITY AT LARGE AS YOUR
DAUGHTER AUBREY HAS RECOUNTED
WHENEVER MILIEU BUCKLEY HAD A
DAY OFF PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
IT'S A FAIRLY BIG INVARIABLY
BECAME A CELEBRATION OF SOME
KIND WITH EXTENDED RELATIVES
COMING OVER. IN LARGE MEALS
BEING PREPARED A MILLION NESTER
ALSO FOUND JOY IN WATCHING
COMEDY AND ACTION MOVIES TO
TAKE THE FAMILY FAVORITE MOVIE
WAS APPROPRIATELY COMING TO
AMERICA ON DECEMBER NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY DURING THE HEIGHT
OF THE WINTER COAT WOULD SURGE
MAMA AMY WORKED HER LAST SHIFT
IN THE HOSPITAL'S OBSERVATION
UNIT IN MORE THAN NINE MONTHS
WORKING ON THE FRONTLINES
INTENDING TO COVERT NINETEEN
PATIENTS SHE HAD SUCCESSFULLY
AVOIDED INFECTION URGING OTHERS
TO DO THE SAME. IN ONE PHOTO
FROM THE PAST YEAR WHICH
CIRCULATED WIDELY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SHE WORE A FULL LENGTH
SCRUBS AND PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WHILE HOLDING UP A
SIGN READING I STAYED AT WORK
FOR YOU PLEASE STAY HOME FOR US
ON DECEMBER TWELFTH LAST YEAR A
MILIEU STARTED EXPERIENCING THE
TELL TALE SYMPTOMS OF A SORE
THROAT FEVER AND SHORTNESS OF
BREATH AND TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVERED HER ENTIRE FAMILY WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF A YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER ALSO TESTED POSITIVE.
FOR A MILLION WHO IS DIABETIC
SYMPTOMS RAPIDLY BECAME MORE
SEVERE AND SHE WAS TAKEN BY
PARAMEDICS TO ST JUDE MEDICAL
CENTER IN FULLERTON ON DECEMBER
NINETEENTH FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN THEIR LIVES THE TIGHT KNIT
BUCKLEY. FAMILY DID NOT SPEND
CHRISTMAS TOGETHER. INSTEAD
MERELY SPENT THE NIGHT FIVE WE
IN THE HOSPITAL. THE LAST THREE
IN THE INTENSIVE CARE UNIT
HOOKED UP TO A VENTILATOR.
UNTIL SHE SUCCUMBED TO HER
ILLNESS ON JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND. IN THE MONTHS FOLLOWING
HER PASSING THE TRIBUTES
CONTINUE TO POUR IN. MESSAGES
CENTERED ON HOW EMILY WAS A
COMPASSIONATE SOUL AND A
DEDICATED MENTOR AND HOW DEEPLY
SHE HAD TOUCHED OTHERS LIVES.
IN FEBRUARY HER FAMILY JOINED
THE HOSPITAL IN THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. FOR WHAT
TURNED OUT TO BE A THREE HOUR
CARAVAN MEMORIAL WHICH MADE ITS
WAY THROUGH THE REGION. WHERE
AMELIA TOUCH SO MANY LIVES.
BACK HOME INTERNET OF
PHILIPPINES TRIBUTES FROM
ILOCOS NORTE RESIDENTS POURED
IN ON SOCIAL MEDIA. AFTER THE
GOVERNOR THE PROVINCE TOOK TO
FACEBOOK TO RECOGNIZE HIM NEAR
FOR HER LIFETIME OF SERVICE.
AND HER HEROISM DURING THE
PANDEMIC. MY JUNE ELEVENTH
EMILY WAS AMONG THE FIVE
AMERICANS WHOSE REMARKABLE
LIVES WERE CUT SHORT BY THE
CORONA VIRUS AND MEMORIALIZED
ON THE PBS. NEWSHOUR SINGH HAS
LEFT A HUGE VOID IN THE
COMMUNITY OF WHICH MAMA AMY WAS
SUCH AN INTEGRAL PART BUT HER
LEGACY. AND HER SPIRIT CARRY ON
A MILLIONBUCKS LIKE IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND MISTER
BUCKLEY. THREE CHILDREN JAMES
ANTHONY BUCKLEY. LOBBY JOY BY
CLICK ENJOY AND MAY BACK LEG.
TWO GRANDCHILDREN TRICIA
BUCKLING INSTEAD CHANGE BACK
LIKE FOUR SISTERS AND TWO
BROTHERS I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED AND HER BELOVED
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN PLEASE BRING THEM
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY A LONG TIME STATE
EMPLOYEE ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENT
AND MY CHIEF OF STAFF'S FATHER.
MOUNTED SHARE THE FARM. MANAGER
WAS BORN IN TEHRAN IRAN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN FROM A
YOUNG AGE AND INTEREST IN
SCIENCE EVENTUALLY GOING ON TO
STUDY BIOLOGY AT THE NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY IN TEHRAN. FOLLOWING
HIS GRADUATION MODEL CHAIR IN
HIS RIGHT WIFE ROKY REGGIE CAME
TO AMERICA TO PURSUE THEIR
GRADUATE EDUCATION AT THAT TIME
DURING THE NIXON FORD
ADMINISTRATIONS NUMEROUS
PROGRAMS EXISTED ALLOWED
STUDENTS FROM MIDDLE EAST TO BE
INVITED INTO THE US TO HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO AMERICA AND ALSO
RETURN TO THEIR HOMELANDS TO
FOSTER PROGRAMS THE
RELATIONSHIPS. BETWEEN BOTH
COUNTRIES MONITOR COMPLETE HIS
GRADUATE STUDIES AT EASTERN NEW
MEXICO UNIVERSITY THEN TRAVEL
BACK TO IRAN WHERE HE SPENT THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS TEACHING AS A
BIOLOGY PROFESSOR AT A
UNIVERSITY THAT WORKED IN
DIRECT COLLABORATION WITH
AMERICAN SCIENTIFIC
INSTITUTIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
TURMOIL IN IRAN THE IRANIAN
REVOLUTION AND ITS AFTERMATH
FORCE MANAGER AND HIS WIFE AND
TWO YOUNG CHILDREN TO SEEK
REFUGE IN GERMANY WHERE THEY
REMAINED FOR TWO YEARS AS
ASYLUM SEEKERS. MANAGERS FAMILY
PATIENTLY WAITED FOR COUNTRY TO
TAKE THEM IN ONCE AGAIN AMERICA
WAS A COUNTRY THAT WILL ACCEPT
THEM. NO ONE ELSE WOULD MODEL
JANICE FAMILY SETTLED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
SPENT THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS WORKING IN THE UC SYSTEM
AS A LAB TECHNICIAN. IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX ONE OF THE
PROUDEST MOMENTS OF HIS LIFE IS
WHEN I BECAME AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN. MANAGER WAS A STORED
FOR HIS UNION THE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSIONAL TECHNICAL
EMPLOYEES AND WAS ACTIVE IN THE
CHRISTIAN CHURCH. IT WAS A KIND
AND CARING PERSON ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR A WAY TO PAY FOR
IT. THE ASSISTANCE THAT HE AND
HIS FAMILY RECEIVED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES HE WAS A GREAT
FATHER. I KNOW THAT BECAUSE HE
RAISED A GREAT SON ARE YOU. THE
LAST. THIS LAST MONDAY PASSED
AWAY SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY
IS HOME IN LAGUNA GAL AFTER
TWELVE YEAR BATTLE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AND PARKINSON'S. HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN SEVENTY FOUR
THIS WEEK IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY YEARS. RAJI HIS
DAUGHTER. ASA DAY IN THE SUN MY
CHIEF OF STAFF ARE YOU. CALLING
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN. THE%
MEMORY OF MONITOR GO FAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
PLEASE DURING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED AT CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- IT
IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
ASKED THAT THE SENATE.
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
RICHARD RAINEY. A FORMER
DISTINGUISHED MEMBER OF THE
SENATE. SENATOR RAINY
REPRESENTING MUCH OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN THE ASSEMBLY
FIRST. FROM NINETEEN NINETY TWO
TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX. AND
THEN IN MY SENATE SEAT FROM
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND. GENERAL TO THE
FORMER REPUBLICAN LEADER OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHO SERVE WITH DICK.
SAID QUOTE. HE WAS ONE OF THE
MOST DECENT ONE OF THE MOST
HONORABLE ONE OF THE MOST
HONEST PEOPLE TO HAVE EVER
SERVED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. AND CALIFORNIA HAS
LOST A TRUE STATESMAN TODAY.
SENATOR RAINY STARTED HIS
PUBLIC SERVICE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS A POLICE
OFFICER IN COMPTON IN NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO. HE WAS HIRED BY THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR AND WAS PROMOTED THROUGH
THE RANKS AS A DEPUTY SHERIFF A
SERGEANT LIEUTENANT AND
CAPTAIN. BEFORE BEING ELECTED
COUNTY SHERIFF IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SERVING THERE
UNTIL NINETEEN NINETY TWO. ZERO
THROUGH THE ROSE TO THE RANK
STICK MADE SURE HE GT AN
EDUCATION EARNING A BACHELOR'S
IN ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE
FROM SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND A MASTERS IN
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION FROM
GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY. SENATOR
RAINEY WAS APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN
DURING THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES TO
THE STATE BOARD OF CORRECTIONS
AND THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES AT
THE ROBERT PRESLEY INSTITUTE.
OF CORRECTIONS. BUT AS INTEREST
WENT BEYOND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHILE SERVING AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. IN TWO
THOUSAND HE WROTE THE BALLOT
MEASURE IN FAVOR OF PROPOSITION
FOURTEEN. WHICH WAS A
SUCCESSFUL THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BOND. TO FINANCE
THE CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION OF
PUBLIC LIBRARIES. HE WAS
DETERMINED TO IMPROVE LITERACY.
AND STRENGTHEN EDUCATION
THROUGH BROADENING ACCESS TO
LIBRARIES. IN HIS TIME AT THE
CAPITOL HE WORKED HARD TO
IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION IN THE
BAY AREA HELPED LEAD THE
CAMPAIGN TO CONSTRUCT THE
pTUNNEL COMPLETED IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. HE WAS A
MATTER OF GREAT INTEGRITY. WHO
LOOK FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE. IN HIS FINAL
YEAR ALONE IN THE SENATE THIS
REPUBLICAN GOT FIFTEEN BILLS
THROUGH THE DEMOCRATICALLY
CONTROLLED LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED INTO LAW FIFTEEN BILLS.
INCLUDING A BILL TO IMPROVE
BREAST CANCER SERVICES- SIR TO
THE MOVEMENTS REQUIRE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS. A BILL TO
ENSURE THAT SURVIVING SPOUSES
OF TEACHERS WOULD LOSE THE
BENEFITS OF THEIR DECEASED
SPOUSE JUST BECAUSE THEY
REMARRIED. AND A BILL REQUIRING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ISSUE EARLY
ALERTS ON MISSING PERSONS.
AFTER YOU LEFT THE LEGISLATURE.
SENATOR RAINY SERVED AS THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
UNDER PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH.
NOW YOU CAN'T MENTION SENATOR
DICK RAINY WITHOUT TALKING
ABOUT HIS WIFE SUE WHO SURVIVES
HIM. THEY WERE A TEAM ON SO
MANY THINGS SHE WAS ALSO A
POWERFUL FORCE IN LOCAL
POLITICS SERVING ON BOTH THE
MORAGA AND THE WALNUT CREEK
CITY COUNCIL. INCLUDING MANY
TERMS AS MAYOR. I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEP CONDOLENCES TO
SUE AND THE SEVEN CHILDREN THEY
HAD BETWEEN THEM BRET MICHAEL
GINA ROB STEVE KATHY. AND KEVIN.
THE HONORABLE RICHARD RAINEY
MAY HIS MEMORY AS A FATHER A
FRIEND OF THE SENATOR AND A
GREAT CALIFORNIA. BLESSING TO
ALL WHO KNEW HIM THAT IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE JOINED
HIS MEMORY THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
RECOGNIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
JULY FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT NINE AM THANK YOU MA'AM
PRO TEM. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
I WILL BE ADJOURNED WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT DAY EVERYONE.